[Musique]
cette semaine la famille de samuel patty
a porté plainte contre les ministères de
l'intérieur et de l'éducation nationale
pour non assistance à personne en péril
et non empêchement de crime les proches
du professeur d'histoire-géographie
dénonce une série de défaillances et de
lourdes négligences qui ont conduit à
l'assassinât le 16 octobre 2020 samuel
pâtit avait été décapité par un
terroriste près du collège où il
enseignait à conflans sainte honorine à
elancourt près de 600 salariés de thales
ont manifesté ce 5 avril mobilisés
depuis deux mois les employés demandent
une hausse de salaires de 4% la
conférence de presse a lieu ce mercredi
6 avril à saint-ouen la deuxième édition
de la biennale d'architecturé de paysage
d'île de france se tiendra du 13 mai au
13 juillet 2022 à versailles sur la
thématique terre et ville lors de la
dernière édition en 2019 plus de deux
cent mille visiteurs avaient participé à
cette biennale à montigny le bretonneux
du matériel médical en partance pour
l'ukraine une collecte spécifique opéré
par l'association des médecins des trois
villages du matériel d'intervention avec
notamment des kits hémorragie pour les
sauveteurs ils ont pu être achetés grâce
à la générosité des médecins 3500 euros
ont pu être récoltés l'hommage à la mi
journée de l'université versailles saint
quentin en yvelines à laurent bouvet le
politologue cofondateur du mouvement le
printemps républicain est décédé en
décembre dernier à l'âge de 53 ans il
enseigne la science politique depuis
2011 à lui et excuse
[Musique]